until just released some more
information on their new Thunderbolt 4
standard so if you're trying to figure
out the difference between Thunderbolt 3
Thunder well 4 and of course USB for
this video is for you and at the end
I'll also talk about Apple and how their
new ARM based max will play into this
and by the way our new premium Apple
product hoody is incredibly soft and you
can find it in our merch shelf just
below this video the first thing to know
about them about 4 is that it uses the
same exact design as it did before so
just by looking at the port you won't be
able to tell the difference between a
regular USB C port a new USB 4 port or a
fundable 4 port so you'll have to rely
on looking up the specs of the computer
or the laptop that you're buying to know
for sure which port it is now before I
get into the specs of Thunderbolt 4 let
me first explain what USB C is and how
it compares to the current Thunderbolt 3
if you already know all of that you can
skip ahead to this section of the video
the USB type-c connector is basically
the solution to the flawed design of the
USB a connector which is known for being
super annoying since you have to plug
something in using the correct
orientation with USB C it doesn't matter
which way you plug it in since the
connectors are in the center so it works
every time
now digging deeper into USB C there are
actually different transfer speeds that
are supported with really confusing
names that were recently updated for the
second time and ironically they're still
confusing there's USB 3.2 Gen 1 which
supports a maximum speed of five
gigabits per second
there's 3.2 Gen 2 which goes up to 10
gigabits per second and there's 3.2 Gen
2 by 2 which goes up to 20 gigabits per
second and the only way to know the
difference is to check the specs of your
computer but the great thing about USB
type-c is that it allows up to a hundred
watts of power to be transferred from
one device to another compared to only
seven-and-a-half watts using the old
square USB type a connector and that's
the reason why Apple's 18 watt
charging brick uses USB see now this is
where Thunderbolt 3 comes in it uses the
same type C connector and it supports
USB C devices but it also supports
speeds of up to 40 gigabits per second
not only that but it's made to support
more protocols like DisplayPort by using
an adapter and PCI Express for handling
data transfer between computers and
things like a GPUs and because of its
high 40 gigabit per second bandwidth
it's able to power high resolution
displays like two 4k displays a single
5k display or even apples 6k Pro display
HDR by using a new version of display
stream compression that squeezes all of
those pixels into a less than 40 gigabit
per second stream and it can even be
used to daisy-chain multiple monitors or
devices together and ultimately end up
with just one cable being plugged into
your computer but keep in mind that
there are some Thunderbolt 3 cables that
only support 20 gigabit per second
speeds so it's very important to buy the
right cable if you want the full 40 gig
speed and one more important thing to
know about thunder both three is that it
almost always requires an Intel made
Thunderbolt 3 controller chip inside of
the computer or a laptop to support it
so every time you see a laptop with
Thunderbolt 3 ports they had to buy that
chip from Intel and integrate it into
their laptop and on the other side a
device like an SSD that supports under
both three also needs a controller chip
certified by Intel which obviously isn't
free so that's why you don't see very
many Thunderbolt 3 devices at least not
chief ones and those Thunderbolt 3
controller chips that I mentioned can
support up to 2 full-speed Thunderbolt 3
ports so for example with Apple 16 inch
MacBook Pro which has four thana both
three ports it actually uses two
separate intel controller chips to
support them however with Intel's newest
mobile isolate processors they're
finally integrating Thunder both REE
into the processor itself no longer
requiring an external Thunderbolt 3
controller chip and now with all of that
out of the way we can move on to use
before before we finish off with
Thunderbolt 4 on March 4th of 2019 Intel
released the Thunderbolt 3 specification
finally making it royalty-free to be
used to form USB 4 which uses the same
type C connector except that it no
longer requires an Intel Thunderbolt
controller or Intel certification this
ultimately means that we should see USB
4 ports coming to basically every
computer and laptop very soon but the
beauty of use before is that it supports
the same 40 gigabit per second speed as
Thunderbolt 3 so you could potentially
use a use before port in the future to
connect a 6k display and to make it even
better USB for can support everything
that Thunderbolt 3 supports including
DisplayPort and even PCI Express
tunneling to use within each of you and
since it no longer requires a
Thunderbolt controller chip high-end
devices like each of you use are going
to become cheaper and more widely
available than ever before but another
important detail to know is that not all
USB for ports and cables will be the
same since Intel is only requiring use
before cables to support a single 4k
display a minimum of 10 gigabits per
second speed and only seven-and-a-half
watts of power delivery so be sure to
buy the correct cable but basically USB
for is the dream you get support for
very high 40 gigabit per second data
transfer speeds and support for
DisplayPort and PCI Express connections
but while being completely royalty-free
and no longer requiring an Intel
controller chip now let's finally move
on to Thunderbolt 4 and the most
surprising thing is that the maximum
speed stays the same at up to 40
gigabits per second but it still
requires a Thunderbolt 4 controller chip
and Intel certification so it doesn't
seem like a very good deal it seems like
most of the changes are oriented towards
quality control so let's take a look at
a handy chart made by Intel starting
from the top Intel is requiring
Thunderbolt 4 cables to support be full
40 gigabit per second speeds so you no
longer have to worry about buying the
wrong cable on accident then about 4
accessories
DOX can now finally have up to four
ports on top of that int'l is also
requiring thinner boat for cables to
support two 4k displays or one 8k
display support power delivery charging
support wake from sleep when using a
thunderbolt dock support intel vtd DMA
protection and support full PCI Express
32 gigabit per second transfer speeds
and that's basically it
the only real new feature is finally
getting forth and about ports on a dock
other than that Intel is simply
requiring everything about for cable and
device to support a higher standard of
speeds and display support so you won't
get screwed by buying a cheap cable and
into also announced that their Tiger
Lake line of CPUs will soon be the first
to integrate them above 4 and therefore
not requiring a controller chip but to
be completely honest all of those
changes don't really matter to me or
regular consumers like me so I'm finding
it hard to believe that manufacturers
are gonna jump to support that about 4
since the minimum requirements went up
making cables more expensive to produce
and now let's finally finish off with
what Apple is gonna do now that they're
ditching Intel chips and using their arm
base chips which will no longer support
Thunderbolt wait stop that's totally
wrong future Vadim right here and as we
were editing the video Apple just sent a
statement to Apple Insider saying that
Apple silicone Macs are going to
continue to support Thunderbolt
despite the switch to arm so basically
that answers the question so if there
you guys have it hopefully you learned
something new in this video and if you
did click that circle above and check
out our Apple product merch right below
this video thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]